cette page culture avec nos lecteurs oui
donc françoise pichon donc on vous
reçoit ce soir pour parler de votre
comédie musicale donc vous revenez sur
scène avec cette comédie musicale donc
cette année c'est un peu spécifique
elle était déjà créé donc en 2004 nous
l'avait monté en 2004 vous l'avais joué
pendant une si 10,6 en un peu bref ça
fait mal hors du coup cette année qu'est
ce qu'il y est de nouveau
alors qu'est ce qu'il ya de nouveau et
bien nous avons une nouvelle troupe
puisque les plus la moitié la troupe a
changé donc nous avons mis en place avec
jean-marc des siens avec qui on a monté
le spectacle de nouvelles chorégraphies
de nouvelles mises en scène nous avons
remanié quelques chansons également
enfin il ya des choses nouvelles à voir
quel est votre rôle parce que c'est pas
évident qu'il ya dans parmi ses nombreux
personnages pour il est votre rôle
exactement et bien jacques carles très
modestement le rôle d'edith piaf
voilà qu'est ce qu'elle représente pour
vous alors elle représente beaucoup de
choses déjà beaucoup d'émotion c'est
quelqu'un qui a su faire passer beaucoup
d'émotion
tout au long de sa vie à travers toutes
ses chansons c'est quelqu'un qui qui
était moderne avant l'heure et lorsque
vous vous interrogez les enfants vous
interrogez les adolescents les adultes
bref tout le monde connaît dit piard
tout le monde connaît des extraits de
chansons face et c'est pas moi un vrai
plaisir
la chanson que vous inspire le plus
peut-être d'objets volants et que tu es
ma part j'étais petit je chantais
toujours la vie en rose et non rien de
rien et puis en vieillissant
j'avoue que j'ai un petit penchant pour
mon dieu et pour
la vie en rose c'est un personnage
arrière façon edith piaf de par sa vie
aussi qui n'a pas été forcément très
facile
qu'est ce qui vous fascine vous chez ce
personnage c'est une femme qui était
c'était un tout petit bout de femme à m
47 c'était pas très grand c'est une
femme qui débordait d'énergie qui avait
une pêche d'enfer malgré tous ses
problèmes de santé et et elle a réussi à
faire parler d'elle et encore maintenant
parler d'elle et s'était quand même
incroyable
cinquante ans après on arrive encore à
parler de toutes ses chansons beaucoup
beaucoup de chansons sont connus est la
presse un répertoire plus de 250
chansons c'est quand même énorme
alors justement nous sommes allés
interroger les saint quentinois mais
nous leur venons nous leur avons demandé
pardon
quelle quelle image ils ont regardé
d'edith piaf non rien de rien je ne
regrette rien de taille à l'eau c'est
plus la campagne de charleroi dont la
chanson la france
mon mari est fan d'edith piaf j'avoue
qu'on regarde beaucoup on a beaucoup
aussi mais le film d'edith piaf
c'était quand même une grande chanteuse
française à je l'aimé bien c'est tout
parce que elle avait une voix
extraordinaire et c'était un personnage
tout le monde l'aimé même les étrangers
les américains partout donc je mange de
mai en particulier c'était mon époque
écoutez pour continuer cet extrait
musical pédaler pourriez nous
interpréter un petit voilà quelques
paroles sur ce qu'il voit la revue mais
voilà d'accord mais je laissais alors
alors 1 2 3 des yeux qui font baisser
les miens un rire qui se repère sur sa
bouche
voilà le portrait sans retouche de la
bloquer
j'appartiens quand il me prend dans ses
bras il me parle tout bas je vois la
viande rosa exercice pas facile à faire
sur le plateau face à la dernière minute
mais pas chez lui le temps que vous
reprenez votre souffle et consorts
remettre de ses émotions regarde un
extrait du spectacle
non
et
et les flancs du mal à passer
essai -
encore 1 2
le jour
et seul mois
on compte 2
un mois
donc françois bisson vous avez également
créé l'intégralité de ce spectacle c'est
à dire les costumes la mise en scène
pour faire avec jean marc veyssière nous
sommes voilà james east vous avez tout à
fait et donc comment s'est passée la
coordination virait entre tous et tous
ses différents membres de la troupe les
musiciens il ya un accordéoniste de gr 2
à 2h10
les danseurs les chanteurs comment vous
avez coordonner le tout alors comment on
a coordonné le tout bas ça pas été
simple je me lave ou alors on est partis
de l'idée de créer cette comédie
musicale pour bien sûr faire mettre à
l'honneur edith piaf et donc on est
parti sur des thèmes sur des thèmes de
sa vie donc c'est une comédie musicale
qui retrace la vie d'edith piaf de sa
naissance jusqu'à ou ne parle pas de
mort parce que c'est pas très gai donc
jusqu'à je dirais jusqu'à son son qu'on
peut dire son
son apogée son apogée ou alors
maintenance à son apogée et
et donc seize comédiens sont sur scène
ses seize comédiens sont des danseurs
des chanteurs des danseuses et donc il
faut bien corrélé tout ça donc il ya
beaucoup de répétitions beaucoup de
répétitions parce que vous êtes un
menteur vous avez une vie faite en
parallèle complètement oui pour notre
langue est exactement en a plusieurs
vies on a rencontré une des danseuses en
qui s'appelle cécile faits qui nous qui
nous explique justement ces variations
entre le temps de mise en scène ou garde
de danse et puis c'est vrai tant de
danse chorégraphiée on va l'écouter la
plein de types de danse en fait parce
que on est à la fois dans la mise en
scène
donc c'est pas réellement de la danse on
est vraiment de la mise en scène il ya
des moments où c'est de la danse mais il
faut que ça trop dense et parce que on
est quand même sur un répertoire où l'as
nancy près tout à fait prête pas
forcément tout le temps et
et il ya aussi des moments où c'est
vraiment la danse moi il ya bien du
moment où je fais de la vraie danse
contemporaine quoi et votre fils
frédéric kirui vous a aussi suivi dans
cet imprimeur c'est vrai j'ai beaucoup
de chance j'ai la chance d'avoir mon
fils sur scène avec moi et c'était assez
franchement un grand plaisir
alors on l'a rencontré au cours des
répétitions également et nous a expliqué
pourquoi donc qui s'est lancé dans cette
aventure
est ce que ça lui apporte cette comédie
musicale on va l'écouter garni on a
beaucoup de rôles donc sur le spectacle
joue souvent l'amant de ma propre mère
c'est une situation un peu délicate je
vous avoue que là on est au théâtre
donc on joue la comédie et donc ça se
passe très très bien et après en
coulisse moi j'ai une relation très
fusionnelle avec ma mère donc du coup
comment a commencé spectacle dès le
début moi j'ai vraiment plongé
l'attendent dans mon enfant donc j'ai
vraiment énormément impliqué dedans et
puis avec manière vraiment navré
tspectacle ensemble on est vraiment très
très très proches ce qu'on n'apprend pas
à l'école je dirais j'ai appris ici dans
cette comédie musicale de ces comédies
musicales font vraiment partie
intégrante de ma vie elle m'a suivi
toulon et je pense que je la continuera
jusqu'au bout et ça me plaît votre fils
si j'ai bien suivi et aussi votre amant
c'est du vaudeville en fait mais sa
lancée dans un autre rien n'est fait ça
faut pas dire ça va bien ça c'est du
théâtre il a raison de l'idiot
particulier à jouer sur scène
oui enfin quand et diamants faut pas non
plus exagérer il ya des petits regards
voilà c'est surtout comme ça qu'il faut
le prendre pour clarifier les choses je
crois franchement public
à vos messages à 6 c'est vraiment pour
tout public vous avez des enfants qui
ont deux ans trois ans quatre ans vous
avez des adultes vous avez des seniors
vous avez de tout âge tout public voilà
et alors donc vous dresser dans au
travers des quarante chansons c'est ça
c'est un peu plus ou moins comme vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'air dont il ne
s'agit pas de chronologie en fonction
des chansons et leur date effective de
sortie mais plutôt une chronologie par
thème par la dnat éléments ex à la
naissance en france
son parcours un peu chaotique dans les
rues dans les rues de paris
ces amendes look umass l'occupation ses
amants c'est pour ça évidemment ou un
grand rôle mais y'a pas confisqué
d'ailleurs loin de là d'ailleurs
et elle en regardant ses amours ses
amitiés rien parti pris je crois dans
cette
quand j'appelle parti pris c'est à dire
vous avez choisi oui volontairement donc
de d'adapter les textes des chansons
c'est à dire que si j'ai bien compris
vous enlever la partie
les derniers couplets qui sont souvent
plutôt tragique plutôt attendre la toute
la partie tragique on a décidé de la de
la supprimer ou de la descente de la
mettre en dérision par exemple mon violi
siens qui est une chanson qui est
interprété par par plusieurs personnes
dans la troupe
et bien c'est une chanson qui est
extrêmement triste puisque c'est la
personne qui est en train d'écrire une
lettre et qui en train de dire adieu à
tout le monde puisqu'elle va elle veut
se suicider voilà et bien lorsqu'on voit
lorsqu'on écoute la chanson et quand on
voit la chorégraphie qui est mise autour
de tout ça on ne se doute absolument pas
de cette histoire
donc on a essayé
tourner les choses pour ce soit quelque
chose de gai et donc cette comédie
retrace vraiment je dirais beaucoup
d'émotion mais beaucoup d'émotion on est
dans la joie et on est dans l'émotion
triste mais sans que l'on soit dans le
glauque
voilà donc c'est des émotions c'est gai
voilà ça c'est très relevé et ses 14
avril et ce week end
voilà il faut venir nombreux à la salle
des fêtes celtiques exactement